first we'll look at this ratio one now
it is a tricky thing to try and keep all
of the ideas in your head
there's a lot I think you can see as
well I have used you can use a
highlighter or a pen or whatever so that
you can sift all the important
information out of this question because
there's a lot there to keep in mind okay
so the first thing obviously is to
understand okay this ratio that's really
gonna matter to be you can see I've
underlined the four and the five what do
you think that's about why am i
particularly done those two very good
you can see in fact we did a question
like this a while ago she moves $6,000
so I shouldn't say she moves $6,000
what's changing is borns
- I should have highlighted this - bonds
- shares right so you can see what
direction the money is going in and the
the ratio that the ratios aren't
reflected at the form of the fire okay
so that's why I've highlighted them in
particular so let me go start to walk
through for the first part over here on
the left hand side I think most people
were ok with this bit they're okay with
this one part there are going to be
twelve parts in total where do I get
that number twelve from yeah very good
so if I want to dish that all out I've
got to slice it into 12 pieces first
then we go here for go here five go
there okay if there are twelve parts
that every part is going to be and you
can see me doing the calculation there
you've divided by 12 and that gives you
the size of each one of the chunks okay
now we talked earlier about like words
and then a kind of thing I have said
there's an old ratio and then there's a
new ratio and I've distinguished them
verbally I don't know how I'll see you
do that in a nice neat unambiguous way
basically we're trying to guess if for
example your solution looked like this
which several solutions did right we
basically had to say okay I think this
is what they're doing because three four
five is in the question and the next
line comes from that ratio and so on but
I don't you can see when you compare
that to that this is clear
much better community right so these
words it'll take you like a second to
write old and new that's all you really
have to do okay now remember we were
pointing out okay $6,000 moves so you
can see in these two lines here where
the movement is of money is can you see
the numbers that change you see the
trees there do you see that $6,000 has
moved from here to here right which is
why this number is 6,000 smaller and
this one is 6,000 bigger okay once you
got your dollar amounts there's only one
step left can someone tell me how do I
go from this second last line here to
this six to seven to eleven ratio what
did I do
I've simplified this ratio what did I
actually like numerically do with the
ratio to super fine okay
so divide my twelve thousand that's kind
of a good strategy to take because each
of the parts was twelve thousand before
however we've mucked around with the
parts yeah so twelve thousand is
actually going to give you some
fractions and that going to be some
point fines so another way to do this
and that kinds of pairs on the numbers
you get is to have a look at the numbers
you get in your new ratio have a look at
those okay the way to get that down to
the simplest ratio that's possible is to
think well what's the biggest number
that I can divide every single one of
those through and still end up with
whole numbers okay I'm thinking about
this like what we were doing fractions
if I gave you this fraction here 10 over
15 you all know we can write this in a
simpler way I have to divide the top and
bottom by something what do I divide by
five right if you divide by five you get
2 over 3 and that's the simplest way you
can write this okay so I divided by
6,000 and that's what gave me my final
answer all right I'm gonna move on to
the next page so if you want to have a
look at your solution for number 10
deviant behavior on that 110 kilometer
per hour highway she looks at the phone
and then she looks up okay so the
question itself is how many meters have
they traveled in that time right so the
first thing you notice is that the
question is about meters but the rate
you've been given is not in meters do
you notice that where is the rain it's
it's the first line right 110 kilometers
per hour okay so that's why you can see
in my work II the very first thing I
have to do is I have to convert
kilometers into meters but that's not
all what other conversion do you see
have a look at my working what else have
I converted and why I have a look at my
top line of working what am i converted
you've got the other part of the ratio
right khloe's were per hour before yeah
and I want them in seconds why why what
them in seconds for yeah good the
question is provided to me a time and
that's in seconds so it makes sense to
try and convert both of the units into
both the units that the question is
giving me okay
once you've got 110 thousand divided by
3600 that's where this number comes from
and what do you do with that number to
turn into the actual distance yeah you
say well that's every second every
second you go that far which is really
far in a second because 110 kilometers
per hour is really fast all right so if
that's one second then I'm going to say
in 15 seconds I multiply through and
that's what gives me my distance okay so
that's question to does they don't want
to ask clarifying questions on that is
that still yeah yep okay excellent
what's next 13 okay let's have a look at
station
okay this is a tricky question so let's
step through it nice and slowly okay
just like the first question we did
whatever was a what something like that
there's a lot of words here and a lot of
information packed into this space so
you have to read really carefully
Charmaine is trying to get feel ready
for her
leaf blower you'll notice as well the
question says that fuel is made up of
petrol and oil got these two parts the
question gives that to you okay and it
also provides the ratio she's got six
litres of petrol and we want to work out
how much oil she needs to add so I want
you to have a look at my working there
start with the left hand side okay I've
just written down petrol to oil is
thirty so what that's literally just the
ratio that's been given to me okay so
how do I turn that what have I done to
turn that into the next line yeah I see
okay 30 to 130 litres to one liter 30
mils to one mil but what I actually have
or what Charmaine has rather is six
liters right there six liters so that
number there on the left-hand side the
30 that represents petrol so I want to
turn that it's choosing your color I
want to turn that into six so I divided
by five which means I divide that by
five and that's where my numbers come
from okay six liters petrol one-fifth of
a liter of oil which you could have
converted to mils if you liked but you
didn't have to okay all right no here it
gets a bit tricky read carefully would
be unless read read nice is serving
Charmaine is three point what litres of
fuel left in her container after Philly
holy [ __ ] does this you see how this
continues for the previous question
right she made up this amount she
started pouring it it's like what I'm
done okay so now she's got this left
over she wants to use this fuel for her
lawn mower but her lawnmower requires
the petrol oil to mix either different
ratio okay so think about this
32 one verses 25 to one which one has
more petrol and which one has more oil
when you can play the leaf blower
and on board mo what do you think the
lawnmower needs more oil right needs
more oil because you've got a smaller
smaller ratio of petrol in there to the
same amount of oil okay good so that's
why the question says how much oil
should she add so that we get it in the
right ratio okay so remember back to
this first part of the question right we
had no oil
he had no oil we had the amount of
petrol and we said well okay for that
amount of petrol
he's about oil you need okay for part
two it's been complicated because
there's already some oil in there right
so clearly the first part of the
question and you can see here this is my
first line the first thing you have to
do is work out well how much is there of
each part like how much is actually
petrol and how much is actually oil now
you can see what I've done I've given my
answer over here but where did I get
those numbers from where did the three
litres of petrol and point 1 litres of
oil where did I get them from ok very
good
I looked back up to here see this that
30 to 1 okay if there's three point one
you can think of it as 31 parts 31 parts
right do you remember that question we
did with three four five there were
twelve parts well here 32 one there's 30
parts here one part here 31 in total if
I've got three point one liters and
there are 31 parts
how big is each part three point one
litres 31 parts you just have to divide
through right and that gives you zero
point one of a laid-up or 100 mils okay
and that's where I've got this number
from and I know that this 30 times is
much petrol in there so that's where I
get its number from okay so then the
final part of the question is and this
is what the second mark is for all right
I've got a hundred mils of oil but I'm
not I'm not supposed to have a hundred
miles of oil right so then I treat this
as a whole new question right here the
ratios supposed to be 25 to one so I go
through just like I did for part one I
said okay this three litres of petrol
how much oil am I supposed to have
there's the number there
what do I do in that to answer the
question what I do it that no I'm sure
right I'm I'm short a hundred mils
that's why we told me at the beginning
that I don't have enough oil I already
have a hundred mils I've worked it out
in my first line so I've got to add an
extra 20 and that's the quantity okay so
a lots going on in that question right a
huge amount if it's still a bit like it
to you I encourage you to come back to
this solution I hope as you step through
it if you understand why I'm running
every number then you'll be able to make
sense of it okay probably what's
happened is if you remember um
yesterday's dead force listen on Monday
when we were having a look at the person
who got a 3% pay rise do you remember
that one so I got a 3% pay rise and then
they got some about we wanted to know
what their salary was before okay
so the difference will be is at 3% of
what you were before or 3% of what you
are now and there's that tiny dollar
amount right the full Mills is almost
certainly you've done the ratio for a
different amount like where you started
rather than where you ended and I can
have a look at your numbers it I could
probably dissect where it happened but
that's why there'd be a small difference
that's where those creepy okay